have I not given you everything that you
wanted a chance to go back to see your
father
this is like a see another broken
[Music]
we need to talk
yes Norah
[Music]
yes we do
the stage is set
world's will live
worlds will die and the universe will
never be the same
[Music]
[Applause]
flash on the webisodes were told Tuesday
January 15th on the CW hey everybody
happy new year reverse-flash is back for
the rest of the season I got a lot of
requests to do a video on the teaser for
his brand new suit people think that
he's gonna be wearing a brand new
costume so I'll try to explain what's
going on with that but the producers in
Tom Cavanagh himself gave a couple
interviews explaining exactly what
they're gonna be doing with his
character in which direction they're
taking this because in the footage we've
seen so far they have this Hannibal
Lecter Silence of the Lambs thing going
on so because it's the holidays will do
a new round that reverse flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
reverse-flash moment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this
we'll talk about the new reverse flash
costume first because that's what most
people are freaking out about right now
then we'll talk about the new previews
that they gave during their recent
interviews which are actually pretty
cool it implies something weird is going
on with an aura storyline we all know
reverse flash is probably manipulating
nor he's already lied to her about a
couple things but they explained that
it's way deeper than that like it's
gonna be way more complicated which i
think is gonna be really cool so if you
didn't see it the reason why people are
thinking that we're getting a new
reverse flash suit is is because Tom
Cavanagh and Carlos Valdez did their
annual greeting for everyone they
usually seen a Christmas song and do
like a little funny skit at the end of
that skit they reveal a couple posters
of a new reverse-flash costume so I'll
just play like a little bit of that here
[Music]
so you see this suit it's definitely
different from the current version of
the reverse-flash suit the reverse-flash
that we've been seeing in the future in
prison with Norah is the same reverse
flash that ran off at the end of the
season for flash crossover when he was
teasing Barry by saying that he might be
wearing a new face when he showed up
again well he's still wearing the same
face but the producers explained he ran
off and somewhere in the future he got
caught thrown in prison in iron Heights
and that's when Nora came to him so as
of right now as far as we've seen him
he's still got that old costume but this
implies that they might decide to change
that in the future they changed Barry's
costume every single season so it makes
sense that at some point they would
change reverse flashes costume but what
they've done here is they taken his
regular costume there's black running
through the helmet there's black
shoulder guards there's the black
lightning bolts down the side the belt
is almost solid black in red instead of
being yellow black and red in all in all
it just looks a little bit cleaner than
the suti has been wearing this whole
time the way they shade the suit like
it's black and yellow but it kind of
bleeds into each other so it almost
gives it this dirty look and even though
they've kind of changed the coloring a
little bit season to season it's the
same basic costume that he's been
wearing this whole time they're too big
concept artists that are responsible for
most of the concept art that you see on
the flash one is Andy poon who post
stuff pretty regularly the other is John
Gallagher
so John Gallagher is the person that
made this season 1 or pre season 1
reverse flash concept art obviously they
didn't go with this this is the one that
Andy poon did prior to season 1 which
they also did not wind up using so this
brand new iteration that they have on
the table here is two different photos
it's this one in this one both John
Gallagher photos but colored to look
more like the Andy poon lines with the
black and the helmet in the black on the
costume so whatever they're implying
with this someone has combined all of
the unused concept designs into one
single design and that could serve as
the basis for what his new costume looks
like arguably maybe when he gets out of
prison or breaks out of prison later
this season so just keep in mind that
this is not a guarantee that he'll be
wearing this suit it's just concept art
that's been changed to look more like a
lot of original season 1 concept art but
I think if they're trying to show the
evolution of the reverse-flash it would
make sense that at some point
he would get a new suit so here's the
thing season five reverse flashes
storyline per the producers in a new
interview is all about his own legacy
they say that he's actually concerned
with his legacy the same way that Berry
is worried about his legacy in his
legacy mostly being Nora and all the
problems she's having so like Barry
looks at the future newspaper he sees
all this crisis stuff going on in the
background he doesn't totally understand
crisis on Infinite Earths but he sees
that things are really bad in things
with Nora are really bad especially with
his family because she and iris weren't
really close in the future so just
things are bad in general the same thing
is going to be happening in the reverse
flashes mind but arguably you know he
has a harder road to hoe because his
legacy right now is as a great villain
to the flash but also the person who
killed Barry's mother it's just a
complete psychopath but remember he
wasn't always this crazy like maybe he
had the seeds in there early but he
became this crazy fanboy that turned
into a villain over time as he started
to encounter Barry Allen when he would
come to the Future initially but at one
point he was a very promising genius
that could have been a very productive
member of society
had things not gone down the way they
did so being thrown in prison over and
over again by the flash by other people
like he's been stuck in the prison here
he looks broken disheveled physically
weaker
he's probably worn down enough that he's
ready to help Nora to do something about
his own legacy so he helps Noor develop
the time language and helps her try to
find ways to save her father so that
maybe you know like at least the early
pitch here before things go off the rail
and his captain cold said the plan
always goes off the rails he thinks that
maybe saving the greatest flash the
world has ever known will secure his
legacy or at least balance out some of
the terrible things that he's done
because they can't save Barry's mother
now she has to stay dead no matter what
but they're experimenting with the
timeline like this at the timeline is
malleable they're looking for ways to
save Barry from crisis on Infinite
Earths that will completely destroy the
timeline their official quote reads we
don't want to do the same villain over
and over and if we had the exact same
attitude with eobard thawne that we've
seen this whole time that's not gonna be
interesting either so he was part of the
pitch from the beginning talking about
the beginning of their season five pitch
like he was always part of their plan to
come this season and I think what we
really wanted
was just see a different attitude from
thawne that we hadn't seen in a
different light and you know there's
this big theme of legacy this season so
when we started talking about that with
every other character and then we go to
thon it's like what does legacy mean to
him so that's what we start to touch
upon in the background Tom Cavanagh goes
on to just talk about how they're
showing a different side different
attitude different aspect of the Thawne
character this season
so you remember though here's the
problem crisis on Infinite Earths is
happening next year and we saw at Nora's
future newspaper from 20 49 there's a
paragraph in that the specifically
mentions reverse-flash and he definitely
sounds like a villain so if he's so
worried about his legacy and he wants to
do some good and help Nora albeit in a
selfish way like something in him will
just come out his true nature will
somehow override whatever his intentions
are right now in the paragraph about
crisis it reads reverse-flash leads army
of shadow demons and that does not sound
like the super fun happy time shadow
demons that makes it sound like he's in
league with the anti-monitor in some bid
to do some crazy damage to the
multiverse that will somehow benefit him
at the end of the day so just keep in
mind that when they first come back it
sounds like they'll be touching upon
this idea of him trying to correct his
legacy or at least balance it out so
that it seems a little bit better but by
the end of the day by crisis on Infinite
Earths and next year's crossover he will
somehow have descended back into some
situation where he winds up being the
great villain of the flash series also
keep in mind the crisis wasn't supposed
to happen until 2024 which was season 10
of the flash but all of a sudden were
having it next year on the TV show so it
sounds like they might use their
storyline Nora in reverse-flash changing
the timeline to accelerate to crisis
because of something that they do we'll
talk a lot about them there's a whole
lot of other stuff that they teased
during the flash 100th episode like the
idea that Nora is not the daughter that
Barry was supposed to have her name was
supposed to be dawn she was supposed to
have a twin the reverse-flash in the
past seemed to chuckle at the idea that
her name was Nora like ah look what
Barry's done now he's changed the
timeline again somehow but that sort of
gets into other things that are going on
with Nora's character so we'll talk
about that when the flash comes back
there'll be more trailers coming for
that pretty soon too but let me know in
the comments what do you think about
this new looking suit and what do you
think happens to the reversal
by the end of the season that somehow
leads into crisis on Infinite Earths
if you guys didn't see Young Justice
season 3 is premiering at the end of
this week I've already done a video for
the opening scene so I'll link that at
the end of this
congratulations Rohit Vinay art you're
the giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to watch that opening scene
and click here for all my crossover
Easter egg videos thank you so much for
watching happy new year everyone I will
see you guys tonight
[Music]